oh hi Brian it's beth comstock of GE I
loved your question what keeps you
motivated I think about that a lot i
like to think i'm in a highly motivated
person but I'm here at Davos and I think
that reminds me of what keeps me
motivated which is curiosity seeking out
new ideas seeking out new connections
here at Davos it's all about the
networking and I'm impressed already
that kind of people are meeting and you
start to think about the potential well
if I took fighting with this open source
platform in Japan and we teamed enjoy
electricity customer in Japan what might
we do so curiosity keeps me vote
motivated and the opportunity to get out
and connect with different people and
and sort of tap into their passion in
their motivation is what it's all about
thanks